[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera a tutti voi questa sera vi
parlerò terapia parlare di terapia non è
qualcosa che si colloca al di là delle
parole e c'è qualcuno che dice che
parlare di musica è possibile che
parlare di musica e come ballare di
architettura ora a pirate l'aspetto
provocatorio di questa affermazione
bisogna riconoscere che di tentare di
tradurre dall ambito sono musicate alle
parole è una sfida ma nella raccoglie
che cos'è la musicoterapia
sicuramente la musicoterapia non è un
massaggio musicale fatto in un centro
benessere e non è una playlist per
invogliare i centri produttivi o
concentrati una definizione consiglia di
musicoterapia quindi sarebbe qualcosa
che è più collegato alla relazione
all'espressione della comunicazione la
musicoterapia si rivolge a persone che
possono avere delle difficoltà delle
difficoltà fisiche delle difficoltà
espressive e relazionali delle vie di
difficoltà e che trovano nel
dell'esperienza musicale la possibilità
di stare
l'azione della musica un altro modo di
esprimersi arriviamo al dunque poi
volesse dire ok tutto molto interessante
ma che cosa succede in una seduta di
musicoterapia che cosa fai
come è possibile suonare conta con
qualcuno che non sa suonare uno
strumento potremmo partire da un esempio
che è quello di un bambino che magari
non ha accesso al canale per bar e un po
parlare pari problematiche e allora che
cosa si può fare si può stare in una
relazione tra pare che faccio un suono
qualità un alto poi io rispondo come un
altro suono
poi magari facciamo sono insieme e
quello gradualmente si struttura in un
dialogo sonoro nel quale bambino forse
può sentirsi nell'isolato compreso in
relazione è forse la potenziale
aggressività che potrebbe venire fuori
anche dal da questa distrazione del
poter parlare potrebbe attenuarsi ma
potremmo immaginare un'altra sito che
sono un altro ambito di intervento della
musicoterapia come per esempio un gruppo
di persone che affrontano la
problematica della salute mentale e
quindi trovarsi insieme poter suonare
insieme fare un ritmo insieme può essere
un'esperienza che va al di là delle
parole al di là del parlare delle
proprie programmi
potremmo anche immaginare un'altra
situazione ancora di musicoterapia che
sono di volti e persone che stanno
affrontando la malattia oncologica e
quindi sentire bene che c'è tra la
musica con qualcuno che vi do una cosa
simile fosse l'ultima cosa che ha voglia
di fare mettersi a suonare gli strumenti
senza sapienti anche suonare
ecco invece proprio li scopriamo forte
farò neanche il metaforico
dell'esperienza musicale poter stare in
una relazione sonora musicale e la quale
mi chiedo se e come visto ascoltato se
che come sto scontando l'altro questo è
fortemente dirompente per chi riflette
sulle proprie dinamiche esistenziali e
anche l'angoscia la paura legata alla
malattia può essere espressa attraverso
scarica sonore di alcuni casi ma
potremmo anche immaginare una situazione
completamente diversa effettivamente la
musicoterapia trova impiego e del per
esempio nell'ambito delle cure
palliative il di magari una persona che
sta affrontando le proprie ultimi giorni
atto dell'esistenza
forse lo straniere l'azione un unico
suono con un ascolto in un certo tipo
proposto in un certo modo poteri quel
senso di condivisione di relazione
precedenza che forse le parole fanno
fatica ad hachiko
potremmo immaginare un'altra situazione
completamente diversa come quella di un
gruppo di adolescenti che hanno bisogno
di sperimentare senza dell'inter che
hanno bisogno di testare la regola che
hanno bisogno di vedere la reazione
dell'altro e quindi provare a dare una
forma anche sonora estrema a quello che
è sempre in quel momento quindi possiamo
vedere che la mia squadra di essi
silentina si applica a tanti montesi
diversi e ed è proprio questa è la sua
specificità e ricerca di portare la
musica non come obiettivo ma come
strumento testamento che è tutto molto
bello interessante ma ok ma che che dati
scientifici come possiamo dimostrare che
le funzioni che è veramente un risultato
perché dovremmo perché sicuramente
sentire percorso magico della birra
ora c'è una crescente mole di evidenza
scientifica gli studi sia quantitativi
che qualitativi che dimostrano che vi
lasciate come si poteva dire sia in
ambito delle bottiglie sia nell'ambito
della salute ambientale ecologia e così
via
per chi fosse interessato può rivolgersi
alla coppia più alle riviste
specialistiche di settore
ma la domanda che vorrei farle cp
insieme infatti anche perché adesso
questo quanto non vi vedo ma è questa
anche se io riesco
a valutare che è un percorso di
musicoterapia a un determinato effetto
sulla capacità espressiva di una persona
che questa è una parte importante lavoro
quello che è realmente significativo può
essere anche tutto ciò che non riesco a
misurare anche questo istante
io sto parlando questa tra scontando ci
sono le vostre reazioni su espressive
pro seriche ma c'è tutto un universo di
risonanze interne che magari non
trapelano si vedono ma che forse sono
altrettanto importanti
paradossalmente mettere un fiore stanza
di una persona malata o ricevere visite
ai bisogni dimostrata questa cosa di
quanto queste significativo veramente
abbiamo bisogno di dimostrare la
necessità di bellezza di una persona che
soffre e questo veramente sistema è la
logica con cui ci poniamo rispetto a
queste cose
e questo comunque non è un discorso che
va a negare l'esigenza di una
misurazione ma è umanizzazione che ci
portatile bene con gli strumenti attuali
lesmo misura di tutta la serie di cose
ma ci sono tutta una serie di altre cose
che sono difficilmente misurabili ma
anche intuitivamente e posso attraverso
l'esperienza testimoniare questo ma
significative la frase di penso con un
bar e si apre questo questa giornata e
queste riflessioni condivise
la trovo bellissima quando abbiamo
pensato appunto di aiuto di fare questo
e spicci e ha colpito perché c'è una
parte della casa e che persone fidate la
volantino ma vorrei risottolineare
dietro particolare e dice quanto segue
ci sono persone che hanno vissuto più
intensamente più largamente più
tortuosamente gli altri che hanno
vissuto la vita esterna conta il
risultato
ciò che abbiamo sentito e ciò che
abbiamo vissuto e allenate la bellezza
di questa grande casi di persone
la cosa interessante che si ricollega
un'altra frase di pessoa che è stata
ripresa da antonio damasio un'importante
neuro scienziato che
il libro di strada mente per intende sul
funzionamento della mente umana e la
parola un punto lorca ed è la frase che
riprende ad esso è questa la mia anima è
una misteriosa orchestra
non so quali strumenti suoni o strida
dentro di me colpe corte e arte timpani
e tamburi
mi conosco come una sinfonia e qui è
l'aspetto interessante perché se io
potessi immaginare di stare in relazioni
con i miei pensieri con la presenza di
qualcun altro con la stessa modalità con
la quale ascolto la musica
forse questo potrebbe agire sul modo in
cui mile nazionale cat e se la
musicoterapia oltre i suoi ambiti di
intervento specifici della disabilità
nella terza età coi bambini turismo e
via dicendo watcher caso di accennare
potessere essere anche un esempio di
come noi possiamo stare in relazione con
noi stessi e con gli altri
forse questo potrebbe avere importanti
conseguenze sociali etiche ambientali
sempre siamo il linguaggio
io parlo e poi questo momento ascoltate
seri parliamo insieme non ci cambiano
la posizione è quella musica può fare
qualcosa di diverso
possiamo produrre contemporaneamente due
suoni e dalla sommatoria di quei suoni
in quei suoni che posso riscontrare sia
me che in questo come modello di
pensiero della relazione può essere
molto importante
tutto questo forse è più chiaro se
facciamo un piccolo ascolto insieme qui
si tratta di una musica
l'interazione musicale
un'improvvisazione con fatto una persona
importante dato pensare anche situazione
eviterei solo concentrarmi sugli aspetti
musicali presenti l'idea persona su una
vita novoli sono in pianoforte e quello
che ha detto di fare stare in relazione
ad ascoltare che cosa sta facendo che la
versione quel momento è stare in
relazione quindi dialogare con questo e
se temete che da english anni del globo
non c'è un certo punto si delinea un
primo frammento me o di una notina poi
un'altra e poi c'è qualcosa che succede
su un avanzamento chiedere di partire
dall'ascolto
[Musica]
con contenuti cercare di portare quello
che succede la questa roba che avete
sentito delle parole che possiamo
condividere solo quale si può difendere
commentare e condividere quindi è questo
che volevo dirvi credito musicoterapia
si è qualcosa che vive negli anni che
specifici gli chiede delle competenze
specifiche sono sera musicali
psicologiche ma che essa può essere
anche un modello di come stiamo in
relazione il come pensiamo il nostro
modo di stare con estese gli altri è un
modo in cui siamo costantemente sempre
più sollecitati da dà tanti stimoli
sonori acustici visivi immagini che
dicendo avere un'esperienza globale io
dico ma come mi sto ascoltando cosa mi
sta succedendo come sto ascoltando
all'altro come può il nostro ascolto
reciproco avere un impatto positivo su
suter e sulla nostra e dell'azione
ringrazio
[Applauso]
[Musica]